When it's 40 or 50 degrees below zero.
You can't blame a guy
for taking boiling water
and blowing off a little steam,
watching it
instantly turn into snow and ice.
But photographer
Joe Chowaniec of Alberta, Canada,
got a kick out
of seeing what other people did
How cold is it?
Cold enough
to use a banana to pound a nail.
Cold enough to beat a frozen shirt
like a drum
to turn genes into a battering ram.
So Joe decided
to do his own game of you, froze
your one off.
The next one was the plate of ramen
noodles.
In 60 seconds,
the boiled noodles were frozen stiff
and frozen in time.
The Frozen in Time series,
I guess I'm calling it
the next experiment, involve
placing an egg on a couple of straws
and cracking it open.
Forget hard boiled.
We're talking frozen solid.
My neighbors were looking out the window
and thought I was crazy.
And finally,
there was something charming.
Make that Charmin
about what
the severe cold did to toilet paper.
People should
make the best of the conditions
they're in,
but don't try using it,
or you will truly freeze your butt off.
In the immortal words of Annie Lennox.
Cold, cold,
cold.
Jeanne Moos, CNN, New York.